how do you spot a child genius gifted
children tend to share three defining
characteristics first they develop
skills at a very young age Mozart began
composing music when he was just five
years old second there self-starters
Srinivasan Ramanujan was constructing
complex formula and theories before he'd
even been taught basic mathematics third
gifted children can be near obsessive in
their investors for William James Sidis
a writer collecting hundreds of
streetcar transfers was a sideline to
learning eight languages by the time he
was 8 he was accepted at Harvard
University at the age of eleven they'd
all have been good candidates for Mensa
an International Society for people with
the highest IQs its youngest member is
just two years old but there can be
drawbacks to being so clever members of
American Mensa are three times more
likely than the general public to suffer
from allergies or depression and they're
almost six times more likely to struggle
with anxiety and these are just some of
the physical and emotional problems that
gifted children in particular may face
spotting those children is important but
many of them are being missed in most
programs for gifted children students
from poor backgrounds are
underrepresented
in 2015 one Florida school district took
the rare step of screening all children
for entry into its gifted education
scheme admissions increased by 180
percent among poor children 130 percent
among Hispanics
and 80 percent among black people's in
other words to spot a gifted child you
actually have to look for them in all
communities not just the ones with the
resources to spot their own the benefits
can be huge when those lost Einsteins
are found the study of mathematically
precocious youth has been observing
5,000 gifted people since 1972 all of
the children had test scores high enough
to get into university when they were
just 13 in adulthood the first 1,650
participants went on to publish 85 books
more than 7,500 articles and have
collectively secured 681 patents 1/3 of
the group earned a doctorate that's 17
times the national average society too
can reap the rewards when genius is
nurtured the founder of Google the
Mozart of maths and Lady gaga were all
discovered as gifted children the child
geniuses who could transform tomorrow's
world are already out there but will we
spot them